when you are preparing for an interview
in the field of autonomous systems it's
important to remember that the questions
you'll consider in this course are just
one piece of the puzzle just as
important is the need-to-know data
structures and algorithms and often C++
a typical interview in autonomous
systems will likely include questions
from both of these areas C++ is often
crucial for these types of positions too
most applications mean embedded systems
limited resources a drone and even a car
can only fit so much compute power on
board latency would often be too high to
rely on cloud compute here certain
positions or companies may let you get
by an only Python such as a role
iterating on deep learning models but if
you work directly on a robot you'll need
C++ we have a separate course for C++
technical interviews as well as material
or some useful data structures and
algorithms to know you can find the link
in the instructors notes below and we'll
also have additional resources at the
end of the course